Уже шість років поспіль наприкінці лютого
родина Гуриків приїздить із Івано-Франківська до Києва.
У Свято-Михайлівському соборі вшановують пам'ять
свого 19-річного сина Романа. Він загинув 20 лютого
від кульового поранення у скроню на вулиці Інститутській.
Нині до суму за загиблим сином додаються
ще й думки щодо зриву судового процесу,
адже п’ятеро обвинувачених у розстрілах на Майдані -
на волі. Колишніх співробітників спецпідрозділу
МВС України "Беркут" обміняли наприкінці грудня
на полонених у "ДНР" та "ЛНР" українців.
- У нашій державі на сьогоднішній день немає
ні правосуддя, ні законів, тому що з тих,
що випустили, по деяких є 100% докази,
що саме вони стріляли і вбивали людей.
Це фото усміхнених "ексберкутівців"опублікував
їхній адвокат Олександр Горошинський.
Нині підозрювані Олександр Маринченко та Сергій Тамтура
вже в Києві. Зустрітися з ними чи поговорити телефоном
адвокат не дозволяє.
Каже, всі пояснення - в відкритому зверненні
на ім'я керівництва країни: президента Володимира Зеленського,
голови Верховної Ради Дмитра Разумкова
та генпрокурора Руслана Рябошапки.
У листі "ексберкутівці" вимагають скасувати закон
про амністію для учасників Революції гідності.
Називають Майдан "державним переворотом",
а протестувальників - "озброєними злочинцями".
Мета їхнього повернення до України -
"відновити чесне ім'я спецпідрозділу "Беркут".
У телефонному коментарі  DW один із адвокатів обвинувачених,
Ігор Варфоломєєв, заявляє, що повернення інших
трьох підозрюваних - справа часу. Ті чекають
на приведення в порядок документів.
Згодом усі планують ходити на судові засідання.
Особливого ставлення за своє добровільне повернення,
каже адвокат, вони не очікують.
- Усі п’ять осіб - вони
Апеляційним судом звільнені з-під варти.
Вони є під особистим зобов'язанням,
яке ще в них письмово не відібрали. Тобто вони
є вільними людьми і повернення Маринченка і Тамтури
як вільних людей у судовий процес.
Які можуть бути поблажки?
Якщо вони вже є вільними людьми,
вони будуть приходити на процес
і в загальному порядку будуть працювати, як і працювали.
Просто будуть удома, серед рідних.
У розстрілах Майдану підозри оголосили
26 "ексберкутівцям" так званої "Чорної роти"
Дмитра Садовника. Та на лаву підсудних потрапили
лише п'ятеро. Решта переховується на території Росії
й анексованого нею Криму.
Дехто навіть отримав російське громадянство.
Видавати їх на прохання української прокуратури Росія відмовляється.
Саме тому звільнення останніх п'ятьох
обвинувачених викликало у активістів неабияке обурення.
Ті блокували залу суду та Лук'янівське СІЗО,
адже боялися, що зі звільненням "ексберкутівців"
зникне й справа Майдану.
Швидке повернення "ексберкутівців" здивувало
громадськість, та не адвоката родин Небесної Сотні Віталія Титича.
- Ці двоє людей, бо саме стосовно них суддя Дячук,
головуючий у процесі, попередньо за два місяці
до цих подій, змінив запобіжний захід,
і цим він оцінив докази обвинувачення в контексті
вказаних осіб,
що не мав робити відповідно
до вимог кримінального процесу.
І з цих ухвал, якими були змінені запобіжні заходи,
вказані особи зробили правильний висновок,
що в цьому суді їм уже нічого не загрожує.
Очевидно, спокійно повернулися
і будуть в процесі далі.
Каже, поки звільнення обвинувачених лише
відтермінувало черговий судовий процес.
Засідання замість січня розпочнеться 17 березня.
Усі мають однаковий склад обвинувачення.
Це вчинення терористичного акту, який призвів
до загибелі 48 людей і поранення 80,
вбивство та незаконне поводження зі зброєю.
За результатами балістичних експертиз
встановлено, що кулі, вилучені з тіл деяких
активістів, були випущені з табельної зброї
затриманих "ексберкутівців". Судити їх можна
і заочно, якщо будуть відповідні зміни в Кримінальному кодексі.
- Зеленський обіцяв, він сказав це публічно,
що цей обмін ніяк не вплине. Для того, щоб він ніяк
не вплинув на розслідування і слідство, яке йде,
треба прийняти зміни до законодавства в частині
судового рогляду і досудового розслідування
за умови відсутності обвинуваченого, підозрюваного.
Це давно нами підготовлене ще в 2016 році.
Але, на жаль, на сьогодні жодного відгуку звідти немає,
і це вказує на те, що дані особи
не поспішають із цим. Отже,
не дай Бог, реалізують другу частину російського плану
щодо відбілювання чи то пак юридичної очистки
осіб, які вчинили ці злочини.
- Син сидів тут, але не за самою клумбою,
він сидів збоку і тримав щит.
І куля пройшла через щит і попала в каску.
І досі на вулиці Інститутській стоїть клумба,
за якою ховався від куль 19-річний Роман.
П'ять кульових попадань по бетону
давно заштукатурили та забілили. Експертиза
цих влучань та закривавленого шолома Романа
довела: стріляли не з дахів будинку, а зі сторони барикад.
- Було дуже шкода. Потім я на них була дуже зла.
А зараз із цією думкою постійно живеш, живеш
і зараз так реально починаєш дивитись на ці речі.
І коли ти розумієш: ну, блін, в тебе ж приціл,
ну, ти ж бачиш, в кого стріляєш.
Ну хочеш вибити з колії - стріляй по руках, ногах,
в плече... Боже, та в коліно вальни - і все.
А це були прицільні постріли: серце, голова, шия. Все, крапка.
Нині не лише "ексберкутівці", а й окремі ЗМІ почали
активніше говорити про те, що в Україні в лютому 2014 року
відбувся державний переворот, а на Майдані
протестували озброєні фашисти.  Такі настрої,
на думку правозахисників, є тривожним сигналом
для нинішнього керівництва країни.
Команді президента вони радять звернути
особливу увагу на справу Майдану, а не сторонитись її.
Правди вимагають і люди.
- Беркутовці, що беркутовці?
Їх послухати, вони свою роботу виконували.
Тут треба копати глибше, а ніхто не хоче, ніхто.
- Про поверненя беркутівців.. якщо чесно,
у мене немає слів.
Як можна було віддавати вбивць?
Подивіться, скільки хлопців і дівчат - за що вони загинули?
На зустрічі з президентом наполягає і
громадська організація "Родини Небесної сотні",
яку після загибелі сина заснував і очолив Ігор Гурик.
Утім, відповіді з Офісу Президента поки не було,
тож батьки розстріляного на Майдані героя
поволі втрачають віру в те, що суд ухвалить обвинувальний вирок.